alors on va revenir sur cette affaire
qui passionne vraiment alors là tout le
monde s'y est mis aussi sur médaille
puisque même que taubira exactement
l'ancien ministre de la justice a publié
sur facebook un long message de soutien
à medel alors mesnel c'est la candidate
de the voice donc a décidé de quitter
l'émission
suite à la polémique de ces messages qui
relayait voilà on avait dit donc des
tests des thèses complotistes à
l'annoncé sur les réseaux sociaux
qu'elle préparait son premier album enel
en préparation de mon premier album je
ne chauffe
je ne chôme pas je m'active elle a aussi
posté un message plus long sur instagram
pour annoncer cette nouvelle
certes j'ai quitté the voice vous êtes
beaucoup à me dire que vous êtes triste
de ne pas pouvoir m'entendre sur mes
autres passages mais là vous m'entendrez
sur mes propres chansons et ça c'est
encore mieux un peu de patience je me
mets au travail hâte de vous faire
écouter le résultat ait de wolfsburg est
là mais on l'est aussi pour moi c'est
pour moi qu'elle aimerait assez sexy
voilà je suis bilingue alors beaucoup de
ces personnes disent qu'elle s'est
servie du buzz pour bon on voit là pour
faire son album derrière
après il ya d'autres gens aussi et je
vous lis il ya des deux qui disent elles
ces voix là mais non elle veut faire son
métier de chanteuse elle s'est excusée
donc elle a le droit de le faire donc
elles les deux partis il ya des gens qui
disent elle s'est servie du buzz il ya
des noms qui dit ce qu'elle doit faire
voilà son métier de chanteuse et qu'elle
a un grand talent c'est ce que je
retrouve sur les réseaux sociaux jouent
d'un petit peu ce qui se dit christiane
taubira l'ex ministre de la justice a
publié sur facebook un long message de
soutien média l'on va revenir vers venir
dans un instant mais déjà que mesnel
fasse un album qui sous-entend c est ce
qu elle s'est servie du bug ou bien vous
trouvez ça normal et qu'elle fasse son
métier de chanteuse que c'est vrai
qu'elle a un gros talent comme enel est
à sa place la chanson et son avenir est
dans la mesure où elle peut plus exercer
son métier de prof d'anglais
c'est la seule issue favorable pour elle
elle s'est excusée l avance
elle vit dans le temps présent je lui
souhaite la sérénité la plus totale
après c'est ce méli mélo dramatique
d'accord donc vous vous aimez vous le
dites vous êtes donc pour paul excuse
pour accepter ses excuses et qu'elle
contribue alors mais la balle à 22 ans
il faut le dire à la main de deux ans
après je vous dis moi ici tous les
indices sont les bienvenus je vous lis
on est ouvert complètement au dialogue
parce que c'est vrai que cette histoire
voilà elle elle fait elle fait couler
beaucoup d'encre et je voudrais juste
rappeler un petit truc c'est que il ya
beaucoup de gens qui confondent la
polémique sur les tweets mais les à
nouveau la monnaie unique je ne veux
même pas parler
pauline et oui on le voi puisque elle
fait ce qu'elle veut sur voila je vois
la vie et on la respecte en tant
qu'artiste avec le voile sans voile
foule dix ans quand voilà au public
sourd je pense qu'elle va aider personne
voilà qui on le voit les ce sont les
bienvenus dans une petite pause 10 6 gdi
kippa voile même matinée c'est vraiment
on est à fond et je vous le dis je
ferais l'émission quand il fera un peu
plus de jour un peu plus tard parce que
le vendredi c'est chabal je ferai à
vendredi avec des gens voilier avec des
gens avec des kippas autour de la table
qui seront chroniqueur d'un soir c'est
super important
[Applaudissements]
après après il ya eu cette histoire de
tweets dont vous vous pensez basse et
votre avis quelle doit continuer et que
elle a 22 ans et qu elle n carrière
devant elle
9 vous jure je suis en complet désaccord
avec maxime game al gore bien sûr que
men elle a droit à un avenir artistique
si elle veut mais pas maintenant
elle aurait dû exercer elle même un
retrait moral je me retire un moment je
ne surfe pas sur le buzz
je me mets de côté c'est le respect pour
les victimes des attentats
alors et le respect pour tous les gens
alors je vous dis là j'ai une info qui
vient de tomber d'un journaliste douch
dont je peux pas dire le nom mais qui
vraiment une info incroyable on me dit
attention alors c'est une information à
prendre au conditionnel
on me dit mais n'a été payée par tf1
pour partir par la production pour
partir par tf1 la production pour partir
unie tf1 ici elle n'est pas partie
d'elle-même c'est avec cet argent
qu'elle peut produire son album c'est ce
qu'on me dit c'est ce que me dit un
journaliste alors c'est apprendre bien
sûr au conditionnel alors mes a priori
c'est ce directement sur les dernières
infos alors à serrer un email grande
halle si ces animaux va être ébranlé je
n'aime pas s'il fallait plutôt il est
bon pour l'instant c'est pas sérieux
c'était bien c'est à dire et ce faisant
ces rayons kiki alors on me dit bien
c'est pas une info c'est une rumeur
bon ok voilà donc cyril est pas une info
c't'une rôdeur oui pensez vous qu'il est
vraiment une seule personne qui
doutaient encore qu'elle soit partie de
son fait
on se doutait bien que lui avait dicté
le texte et qu'on l'avait gentiment
demandé de partir
on savait bien maintenant effectivement
le problème pourquoi est ce que l appel
à l'acteur de faire de l'album
maintenant c'est que du coup on mélange
tout a commencé par même toskala veut
que je respecte mais qui mélange tout on
parle d'une voix alors que c'est pas du
tout la polémique la polémique si les
tweets qu'elle avait sur le terrorisme
ceva la région de l'himalaya
on a vu on a en allant sur facebook elle
a dit qu'il reviendra à l'école cher
mais neil la sphère dur je l' ai
découvert tardivement du fait des
déplacements successifs en de france je
pourrais en rire éraillée voilà dès que
j'ai loupé je m'éloigne ce pays ces gars
mais cette histoire ne donne guère envie
de présenter votre voix imbibé d'émotion
et de chaleur et pleine de personnalité
et ses interprétations que vous donnez
d'hallelujah est un enchantement la rixe
et baptiste alary merci alors on vous
reproche votre turban mais non il me
répond c'est le trail à l'ouest mais des
gens qui étaient vénère sur le nom et
messieurs c'est pas mal non mais sérieux
en amandes grillées d'allah et souriante
traitement et la moelle à parcours je
dis bravo à tf1 ben oui d'avoir laissé
bien sûr là parce que c'est vraiment
bravo à la production avaient marre vous
vous vous dites quoi après je vais
revenir un peu sur ce qu'a dit que moi
juste moi les gens qui pensent qu'elle
serve sur le buzz ou pas mais si elle le
fait elle a bien raison de le faire je
pense qu'elle a été très bien conseillé
c'est le meilleur moment pour elle de
transformer l'essai alors qu'on l'a fait
quoi toi tu côté on va enlever par
rapport à l'ascension et les salles pas
omis la veine hystérie collective autour
d'elle gillet la fête
les balades cgt puisse désormais les
salles à voilà le pen est la règle du
les propos très dangereux n'avait pas
transformé l'essai elle a fait des clips
pour lesquels elle s'est excusée malgus
je vais te dire un truc sur lui dit
ludivine arrêté du tombé dessus comme ça
et elle dit juger irez-vous deux minutes
c'est pas non plus un drame donc on va
se calmer je vous dis ludivine dit juste
qu'elle transforme l'essai par rapport à
son ballon bien c'est par rapport au
social à paris sa prestation dans the
voice arrêter l temps je n'ai pas laissé
par rapport à ses tweets ne dit pas de
bêtise non mais reconnaissez ciel qu'il
aurait pu attendre un petit peu faire
des solutions balle et peut-être jamais
pratiqué la santé pour tomber dans
l'oubli dans l'oubli mais on ne surfe
pas sur une polémique aussi négative
mais justement il ya une hystérie qui
n'auraient pas lu qu'ils ne devaient pas
avoir fait parler prévu en raison de la
polémique et veut tourner la page
elle va chanter elle peut rien faire
d'autre qu'elle chante alors dites nous
ce que vous en pensez vous est ce qu'on
pensait que mais elle doit faire son
album tout de suite est ce que c'est une
bonne décision qui veut réagir là-dessus
encore alors moi on m'a interpellé le
week-end dernier à marrakech un taux qui
m'a vraiment choquée mais c'est avec toi
tu montres
hélas un gars qui mérite un 11 est ici
ou sur un soleil
[Applaudissements]
si on m'a dit mais n'est look évidemment
là bas aussi ça fait un buzz terrible
cette histoire rappelez vous qu elle à
chanter halleluyah dans ce vol ce avec
une partie en anglais une partie en
arabe
elle a transformé les mots en arabe la
traduction est là dessus on m'a dit moi
je ne comprends pas la ram
malheureusement je vous une très belle
langue
on m'a dit vous devriez traduire ce
qu'il a dit pas trop se faire longue
étonné comment tu vas pas faire je lance
le truc c'est gatti pourra dire plutôt
chaud qu'on a dit ça mais qu'il avait
trente minutes de déraper pendant
l'émission permet aux intrus semer
l'émoi attend deux minutes avec wii fit
et un bar où je suis je le fais je vais
le faire pour la wii puisque non mais
chez le père pour lundi devrait arrêter
tu veux dire vous en faites pour ce soir
vous a rien fait pour toi conneries non
mais c'est vrai moi je bosse comme un
fou
alors est ce qu est ce que vous savez
pas ce que vous vous donnez votre sinon
vous avez un avis à donner
oui je veux un avis oui ben alors bah
oui nous eh ben c'est la parole voilà je
trouve que j'ai demandé au micro
évidemment le fait qu'elle reste dans
une émission populaire qui passe sur la
télévision
marv revanche après on va pas non plus
envoyé à guantanamo elle a fait son mea
culpa maintenant l'acte mais le droit
d'exister quand même même artiste
éléments après cette affaire faut quand
même arrêter un peu et c'est votre à
blanc je prends tous les avis c'est ça
qui est important ici dans cette
émission on les prendra tous toujours
booba jambes écoutez moi j'étais assez
de rekem effectivement elle a été
sanctionnée évidemment qu'il faut qu
elle existe effectivement pas la foudre
en tôle ou voilà on s'est cru là dessus
les tweets je considère toujours qu'ils
sont pas possibles alors mais maintenant
effectivement la maire de lille s'en
était pas parce que vous avez
moi j'ai été choqué évidemment par les
tweets mais il faut évidemment qu'elles
fassent et le temps qu'elle fasse cet
album il va pas sortir tout de suite
bien sûr largement tendant mois huit
mois de sébastien patoche avec cartman
on a mis bien dans quelques mois des
moines pour une victoire il y avait
moins de polémiques ou iag à terre
mademoiselle qu'en suisse surfer sur le
buzz comme la comme l'a répété maxime
leboeuf je veux apporter d'être lynché
publiquement et de perdre son travail de
prof d'anglais
donc si elle peut elle de son côté
sortir un album avec ou pas l'argent du
tf en soit là est là elle a dès lors
elle était sûrement ici à la normale a
été elle a été sanctionnée mine de rien
par son départ de the voice
ils sont dans la aujourd'hui à la halle
à noël elle essaie de te faisais des
études de pont devenir progrès elle a
arrêté
donc voilà on bascule pour stationner à
voir là dedans les téléspectateurs et la
vie également de keddy un mois je pense
maçonné bien sûr qu'elle sauve sur le
buzz mais je pense qu'elle a tout à fait
raison parce qu'à un moment donné quand
elles passent dans the voice on est
obligé de la regarder
oui ça veut dire ça dérange les jambes
il y en a qui veulent plus la voir mais
là va faire un truc en solo c'est à dire
qu'on aura l'occasion de choisir si on
veut la voir ou pas si on veut frais
sera libre à chacun exactement à l'est
la bnrm et sur la tête de ma mère
et vous eh ben tu veux que je lis toi et
ben c'est pas la mémoire ou de rumeurs
sans déconner un ténor et y est
non non non kelly alors qu'elle il faut
vous dire elle est extrêmement
intelligent à chaque fois qu'elle prend
la parole c'est pour dire quelque chose
d'intelligent
[Applaudissements]
alors j'ai cherché à ce que vous trouvez
normal que men elle enregistre un album
alors on va voir les la suite bonne
nouvelle 46% mauvaises nouvelles 54 ans
doit envoyer les gens que ce soit
d'accord la majorité donc sont pas
d'accord sont plutôt du côté de gilles
d'isabelle de matthieu delormeau bien
c'est moi vous avez montjean chambre
basse a une nouvelle fois les cherry en
l'occurrence m'en fiche
honnêtement un million mais se dit on
n'arrivait plus à autre chose la mersey